You're lying in bed at 2 p.m. still in
yesterday's clothes. Sound familiar?
Most people in their 20s are
experiencing the exact same motivational
death. You spent 16 years training for
clear goals. Homework, grades,
validation. Then you graduated and the
scoreboard disappeared.
Just an endless void called the rest of
your life. Your brain is literally
confused. It's bored with good things.
that promotion you worked two years for.
Your brain celebrates for two days, then
asks, "What's next?" Meanwhile, you're
drowning in infinite choices while
everyone on LinkedIn is thrilled to
announce their success. Your 20s are
supposed to be messy. Delete the
timeline. Burn the comparison scorecard.
Your motivation isn't broken. It's been
hijacked by expectations that were never
yours. Take your motivation back.